it's a special day of work for a beer
sardi of the Al Akhbar newspaper in
Egypt she's been named on the reporters
without borders list of 100 information
heroes for years she's dedicated herself
to protecting journalists she writes
about injustice speaks publicly and
trains journalists minitokyo as women if
there's a climate of hate every
journalist who wants to report on a
particular event is harassed by all
involved by demonstrators as well as the
security forces that have sadly become a
part of these events what am I knew as
well and thought of unfilial as a 12
reporters have been killed in Egypt over
the past three years appear sadi says
journalists have become targets of
violent attacks and can't report freely
she says there's no protection from the
state from employers or workers unions
she is demanding change and fast it's
just not on the journalists are afraid
and so stay at home when there's
something important happening on the
street we have to document events so
that they can be understood later on
awesome a bear sadi says so far no one
has been held to account for the deaths
of the Egyptian journalists their
portraits have been painted on the wall
of the trade union building to act as a
reminder to all